really I've got to figure out how to do
that chair backflip thing
so Killer Elite stars Jason Statham
Clive Owen and Robert De Niro one of my
favorite actors of all time that's a
great cast I love all three of those
actors I think the Jason Statham is
obviously a really good physical actor
but I also think he's a good actor I
think that he is a good actor I really
do a Clive Owen is great Robert De Niro
he's Harbhajan ear for goodness sakes
he's awesome so the plot of this movie
um hmm here's the problem I just saw
abduction as well and that flaw was very
convoluted and hard to follow killer
elites plot was even more hard to follow
no you have no idea are you messing with
and she is not mom he's like a father to
you right you don't do this there's a
dead man I'm gonna sum up the plot of
killer lead to the best of my ability
but there are a lot of plot points in
the film that I really didn't even grasp
and really lost me so we have a sheik
who's upset because three of his sons
were murdered so he decides to kidnap
Robert De Niro and force Jason Statham
to find these three people who killed
his three sons videotaped them admitting
it and then kill them and then there are
a lot of a whole bunch of other things
going on under the surface that we can't
really grasp and I couldn't anyway
that's the plot of the movie that's also
my biggest problem with the film
couldn't follow the plot it was all over
the place and it was a really poorly
structure of this film it seemed like it
was gonna end but then it kept going and
then it ended again and then it went a
little bit longer than it ended for real
the tone was just off and like a just
really out of place the tone listened
Danny's gonna come back for me
but he does you're out of here is your
worst nightmare
there was one scene where there was a
lot of shaky cam that annoyed me because
you don't need shaky cam and you got
Jason Statham the dude is a freaking be
a he can cake but he's good at it you
don't have to use stupid shaky cam to
hide the fact that he can't do stunts
because he can you don't need to use
that there's one scene where he fights
Clive Owen I was like dang it why are
you using the shakey cam it would have
been so much better if he didn't but the
reason I brought that 1c nobs because I
want to highlight the fact that shakey
cam really isn't used that much in the
action in this film and the chases and
the fights and the gun the gunfights
there ain't that much shakey cam which I
was really happy about there's some
really good stunts in this movie by all
three of the actors I really really like
fight scene that De Niro had I had a lot
of fun that seniors brief but I really
enjoyed it
all three of the actors of this movie I
really liked DeNiro was a lot of fun I
really liked his character he kind of
reminded me this character and Ronan
which is a really underrated action film
as well I like Clive Owen and Jason
Statham I thought this was one of his
better performances in movies recently
he he had like a lot of his character
had more depth than the usual Jason
Statham movie I like to say Jason
Statham I like go through these guys and
that's why I had some enjoyment in this
film I was able to enjoy certain aspects
of it my problems with it though it's
just the plot I couldn't follow it for
the life of me I was trying to pay
attention really hardcore to this pot
and I just couldn't get it I couldn't
grasp everything that was happening it
was too much I wasn't of it's a buzz saw
scientist
it was actually a lot more long
conversations and meetings that took
place in this movie that I was not
expecting I was expecting to be a little
bit more straightforward action but it
was almost a little political at times
and I I didn't really feel like that
worked for this type of movie it's the
better movie over abduction for sure
both films have really messed up hard to
follow plots but the acting of Killer
Elite is off the scale better of course
if you're a fan of the three lead actors
like I in the probably also if I
enjoyment in it but it's just not a
great movie unfortunately I really
wanted it to be but it's not so I'm
gonna give Killer Elite a C+
so that's what this is all about I gotta
cover my expenses if you liked my review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuntman highs